The point of view of a woman who is
undergoing menstruation,
postnatal bleeding,
is it prohibited or optional for them to
fast? Let's start. As far as the woman
who are undergoing the menstrual cycles
or postnatal bleeding, according to our
beloved Prophet Muhammad it's mentioned
in Sahih Bukhari, also in Sahih Muslim,
that it is forbidden for a woman to fast
who is bleeding during the menstrual
cycle or postnatal bleeding. So, it is
not optional, it is forbidden. And the
reason is because when the blood flows
out
in a lady, in a woman,
she loses a lot of blood.
And on top of that if she fasts, it will
not be good for her health. So, Allah
Subhana Wa Ta'ala, it is his mercy that
he has exempted them and made it
compulsory not to fast, otherwise it may
be damaging for the health. And Allah
Subhana Wa Ta'ala does not want to
overburden any of the human beings. So,
that's the reason they are exempted from
fasting, and even in the middle of the
day
if the menstruation begins, they have to
break their fast.
Even if it begins a few minutes before
sunset, they have to break their fast,
but they have to compensate later on.
But
if they're undergoing the menstrual
period, and if the period stops just
before Fajr,
even if they did not have a bath, they
can start their fast.
But if it ends even a few minutes after
Fajr, they cannot fast.
They have to break their fast, and they
have to compensate later on.